welcome to this video playing in
Tichenor master Ziggler from from Norway
let's see ya that once again let's see
what line we get ya Bishop e3 this is an
interesting line quickly and taking
control of the c5 Square and trying to
interesting yeah I know that this is a
way to play but didn't really expect it
ok
hmm okay yeah 95 yeah this was the idea
all along let's see if ifs are probably
going to play a form and I good i cannot
i cannot easily play c5 maybe I should
really prepare it further takes an ITEX
it doesn't really it doesn't really fit
well this should age 5 or so an idea
yeah so I need to play c5 without c5
this position that's really a bit
pointless but D takes Knight takes hmm
yeah he takes Knight takes goes into a
pin instantly okay well i don't i really
cannot make it work so let's just play
some other useful moves maybe I can play
F 6 m-f six takes and if the f pawn
takes something like Bishop g5
activating in this way yeah I know this
is a this is an idea so I'm still
surprised as it I think we can play d 50
I completely overlook this one
wow that's ugly the question is mmm yum
nite nite III is probably completely is
it is it completely ridiculous night III
this also see takes be three hanging and
this is important come on i apply that
if it's not working whatever it's just
in its game yeah and now i take take
here that's really strange t6
yeah probably i should i should move it
what a strange game mmm what happens now
if him yeah if you place that stem I'm a
piece up right yes but of course he's
attacking on on e3
hmm
mm yeah there's no way to really justify
that very interesting my ideas Bishop e3
Bishop be 6m at least Im get this d8
Bishop out of out of this place on d 8
and while the white is better of course
the question is some how bad is it the
pawn on d6 at the moment is Sam located
hmm difficult
White is better but I'm not quite sure
what his plan is I mean it looks very
nice but how do you actually get ahead I
don't well hm the queen on before looks
exposed but how do you play against it
is taking quite quite some time yeah I
understand to understand ready because
it looks like there should be something
I would certainly vibe if I would if I
had wide I would certainly expect that
there is some some way to some way
forward nights you five yeah maybe truth
maybe the south to get rid of some
pieces the king on d 7 is also not bad
to block to block the points the
structure is still very very solid be
six maybe yeah I don't want that be 68
only has before
be firm he's still as before coming
again that's a bit of a shame
how do I get some counter play
maybe that maybe I should have played f6
some point but I don't do any no one
yeah you can just play before in this
battle yep charu PA this route 87 is
coming and this is it's really passive
for black and I don't I don't see how to
avoid it and so just not good
takes King see 6oz my idea I hope this
is tactically working and not
immediately falling apart oops I didn't
see that move at all is it good let's
let's push check time morning
check check check black for fix on time
yeah I'm still trying to make moves I
should just play any any any crap to be
quick just he just played played random
stuff and was quicker than me at the air
was also ahead on time but it took me
some time to figure things out yeah well
I was I was under under lots of pressure
anyway so it's probably not not the
wrong result in general terms besides
the fact that King da just wins
instantly winning the bishop which he
put into a self trap okay y'all very
tricky but I'd like to I'd like to
figure out this this stuff this was
really fascinating ok so I took on c4
ignoring this d5 idea and of course I
shouldn't do that i should play him some
other move the thing is he's not really
threatening something in this this
moment I mean not threatening to to take
or c5 is not so in so terrible so I not
don't really need to take I know he
played that and hear what I really fail
to see is that ok I'm attacking the
knight on b3 so I maybe have some other
moves than 93 but this is interesting
Quincy one very very cold-blooded answer
and the question is what should I do now
I really understand what I didn't see is
this t6 idea which is really cool
I could have taken here actually yeah
this is this is stronger you can get all
the material back of course something
like this and this should be okay the
alice is probably okay for black very
complicated stuff so i took and he
played this d6 move which is really cool
the computer suggestion is really great
great he plays it what's the play age
three I don't understand the move what
about this
wow this is great this is great stuff
yeah of course impossible for a human to
see I mean okay well if you go if you
play this Bishop d8 then the computers
point is if white takes here I can take
here because after Bishop takes b6 that
is this is insane there's the smooth
threatening night xe2 and if takes a
check check kingi one check and at the
end of all this black is a piece of
dowel I'm completely insane variation
this means that probably after after h3y
turn should play something else this is
another is a move queen bee three
between III adder and this is completely
crazy but compared to the game at least
the king position is better I mean white
skin position is worth so I have
something to play for the idea on why
does justjust better Oh Oh interesting
f5 is a strong yeah yeah what a game
this is really interesting you played
that one f5 is cool after eat eggs f
okay for my queen is trapped so it just
means I'm I need to do something really
crazy and this is of course a very bad
config
region what is winning with queenie
three yeah this i'm still at five is
strong and now we got into this and
around here around here i need to
improve rook air-five is not good yeah
okay for this is this is the point if I
get this pawned everything is fine
because if this fails of this faults
then if I've is also week yeah this is
the equalizer and after that a three is
just very strong now we get to to this
position where white is better without
any any big question it was just a mere
coincidence that either he blundered
here with b5 and I could have played
picking yet and at the end we had the
usual usual usual um time scramble
witches not really just related all
right this was very interesting thanks
for watching